after player reaching out patting deck
prescott on the back rubbing his head
giving him a hug you can hear the crowd
prescott extending a fist up in the air
and prescott is in tears
this is
your worst nightmare
badly broken ankle for dak prescott
against the giants in week five of the
2020 season all indications are recovery
is going well he'll be ready to go the
first problem though for him and the
cowboys is what will be the financial
terms of the ongoing relationship
between dak prescott and the cowboys in
2021 and potentially beyond so we're
gonna play a little true or false to
discuss the
the cowboys offseason and we're going to
begin with that prescott true or false
shireen dak will sign a new deal
with the cowboys this offseason and not
franchise tag a new long-term contract
true or false
well i say it's true mike simply because
the cowboys can't afford that franchise
tag they've got to get this done and
they've got to get it done before march
9th with checking my calendar is next
week so they each side knows what the
other wants there should be no surprises
they've been through this for almost two
years get it figured out but i do have a
question for you
let's say they don't get a deal done
okay march 9th let's say for the sake of
argument they don't franchise him
who is going to sign him and how much
are they going to give him considering
he is coming off a couple of ankle
surgeries don't know how that ankle's
going to respond not going to be able to
run until april or may d are people
interested in him or people giving him
mike 35 to 40 million dollars a year in
a long-term deal to sign him at this
point
well you know that's what i've been
saying for the last year though because
people express uncertainty as to what
that prescott's market value is what's
he really worth the reason we don't know
is because the cowboys have prevented
him and anyone else from finding out
even last year instead of using the base
franchise tag the non-exclusive tag
which would have entailed a much lower
franchise tag number far lower than 31.4
million they use the exclusive tag that
prevents anyone from talking to him
anyone from signing him anyone from
saying yeah we'll give up two first
round picks for dak prescott so the
cowboys made this bet the cowboys are
the ones who have kept
us and back and anyone else from finding
out what the market is for his services
so
hey if the cowboys think his market
doesn't start at 37.68 million per year
in new money and that shouldn't be
influenced by the reality that next year
he'll make 45 million under the
transition tag or 54 million if he's
franchise tagged again
let him become a free agent
let him become a free agent yeah let's
see what's out there let him hit that
48-hour window
where his agent todd france can talk to
anyone and by the end of that 48 hours
they may realize holy crap there's
nothing better than what the cowboys
have been offering and you know we don't
really want to leave the cowboys because
being with the cowboys being the cowboys
quarterback unlocks all sorts of earning
potential and post-career
jobs in broadcasting and i know dak is
has pooh-poohed that and i don't think
the cowboys should get a discount for it
but
but if all things are equal
you take that job with the cowboys and
so
we don't know what someone else would
offer that may be the only real solution
here now at
the question i would have and the
concern i'd have if i was the cowboys if
you let him hit the market he leaves
just to prove a point
but then at that point i'd say see you
later if that's it that's it i just
think that's a better outcome
than 37.68 million which would buy you
one more year as a practical matter or a
long-term deal with 37.68 million this
year as the leverage that's going to
drive the number up so um
i i just look i'm a big fan of guys
being able to go to the market and if if
we're going to have this undercurrent of
well nobody else is going to pay him
what the cowboys are pamela there's one
way to find out let him become a free
agent and we'll see what someone else
would pay him yeah and then at that
point you use the 10th overall pick mike
on a quarterback you draft your
quarterback of the future and you hope
he's as good or better than than doc
prescott frankly but
you know i i am curious what his pri
what he would get on the open mark and
i'm very curious about that i'm sure
he's curious about it too i'm sure the
cowboys are curious about it but i do
think over the next seven days that the
cowboys get this still done and i don't
know why i'm so confident with this
because like i said they've had two
years to do this and they haven't gotten
it done yet
but i just have a belief in jerry
jerry's never let a player leave who
he's really wanted to keep i mean he's
always managed to do it now dax been the
one guy who's kind of drawn the line in
the sand and hadn't let jerry get in his
ear and convince him to take the deal
we've seen it done many many times
including dez bryant at the 11th hour
after they franchise tagged him a few
years ago so
who knows how this ends mike but i am
going to bet that the cowboys get this
done over the next week if not the next
week they get it done before july
i remember with demarcus lawrence he put
the squeeze on the cowboys to get a
long-term deal done well before july 15.
july 15 is usually the deadline but for
dak
again you don't want to carry 37.68
million into 2021 you want to get a
lower cap number and if you sign into a
long-term deal you will have a lower cap
number for this year also you don't want
to use the second tag on dac because
then if you ever tag him again let's say
you do a four year deal and four years
from now we're trying to figure out what
the cowboys are going to do next well
dak would be looking at a 44 increase
over his cap number for the last year of
his contract because those tags stack on
top of each other so you don't want to
use it the second time you want to hold
it for the next time his contract comes
up because he's going to be your
quarterback for another 10 or 15 years
the way that things are going for nfl
quarterbacks if you want to keep him
he's going to be a guy who has multiple
additional contracts and once you use
franchise tag number two it makes it
very difficult to ever use franchise tag
number three because of the 44 rule also
this is a nuance that
gets lost on a lot of
fans and the agents don't like it when i
talk about this but but
there is a fundamental difference
between
the value of a contract
when it's given to a guy while he's
still under his rookie deal we get
obsessed with the new money average
because it's always going to be higher
than the value of that new contract from
the moment it's signed there's no such
thing as an extension in the nfl they
don't take your current contract and
staple a new one onto the end of it they
tear up your contract and they replace
it with a new one agents desperately
want those contracts to be valued based
upon
the new
money because if you look at only the
new money and you run the numbers on the
average it's always going to be much
more than the full value of the deal but
with dak
you're starting off full value and let
me give you an example
desean watson's contract new value new
money value of 39 million per year when
he signed it in september if you look at
it at signing
it is 29 million
the value at signing 29 million per year
and that's relevant here because when
you're looking at dax deal
you know you get
37.6 million
as your average at signing
that's just a couple million behind
patrick mahomes who was at 39.8 million
at signing so these are real factors
that that complicate this
and that that we'll see whether there's
any capitulation by dak prescott but you
know what if i'm back i'm tempted to say
i'll just go one more year 37.68 million
and next year i'll hit the open market
and then we'll find out what i'm worth
so are you saying true or false so they
get this done before july 15th mike
i think false i think they don't get it
done and i think either they do the
franchise tag again this year or they
let him hit free agency and he leaves
that's what i thought but i think the
more likely thing is 37.68 because
really why would he at this point
why would he do an about-face on the
approach he's taken from day one
telling the jones family no thank you no
thank you no thank you you know that the
tactics you've used with others throwing
the arm around me and saying aw shucks
and please see it our way it's never
worked why would it work all of a sudden
he's got the ultimate leverage 37.68
million
for 2021 and then a ticket to the open
market next year you
you you know you're you're at the
10-yard line
so you can either be daniel jones and
trip over your own two feet or you can
run it into the end zone and for dak
prescott running it into the end zone
means taking the thirty seven point six
eight million
yeah i it we'll see if that happens mike
this is gonna play out and we're gonna
know at least something next tuesday
whether they tag him or not whether they
get a deal done or not and then the next
deadline we look at is july 15th so
we'll see what happens in the next week
you know if there are reports that come
out that they're getting close or
they're talking or whatever the case may
be but we're going to see what dak
prescott does for next season i do think
if he plays under the tag let's say they
do tag him i do think it's his last year
in dallas just like kirk cousins left
washington i think dax headed out the
door
then why bother let him walk away now
that's the thing if your choice is 37.68
million for one more year or let him hit
the market now if you're the cowboys let
him hit the market now and let's let's
let's see what someone's going to pay a
guy who can't run yet after breaking his
ankle last year i mean at a certain
point you have to be ruthless about it
to get the best possible deal for your
team and that may be what they have to
do all right let's hyper drive through
these last three true or false ezekiel
will bounce back and live up to the
contract he signed a couple of years ago
i'm going to say false mike he just
hadn't looked like the same back over
the last two years i mean the first
three years of his career he averaged
over 100 yards per game he averaged 4.7
yards per carry the last two years 75
yards per game 4.3 yards per carry now
how much of that is dallas's offensive
line which hasn't been the same over the
last two years there may be something to
that we may find that out this year if
tyron smith and zack martin and lyle
collins can stay healthy he's going to
have should have a good offensive line
again maybe it's some of the offensive
line but i just don't think that ezekiel
elliott has looked like the back that we
saw the first three years of his career
mike
yeah i agree with you and sometimes
these guys can just burn out early in
their careers and it's hard to get back
to where you were once you kind of slide
off the horse he's still great but he's
not great at the level that that
contract that he got would suggest true
or false dan quinn was the right
defensive coordinator to improve the
cowboys defense which was abysmal last
year under mike nolan
i'm going to say true because i i think
a lot of dan
quinn as a defensive coordinator i think
he did great things in seattle he kind
of brings back that tampa two defense
that the cowboys played under and in
fact were were okay two years ago with
the defense that they had and mike nolan
came in there and really destroyed it i
mean they were 23rd and overall defense
31st against the run they just weren't
very good last year so i think he gets
them better mike just by what he does as
a defensive coordinator because i think
got off a lot of him as a defensive
coordinator got to upgrade the talent
but i think the coaching is going to be
better
always helps too to have another guy
with head coaching experience around to
be a conscience to be a voice to be a
counter to be especially when mike
mccarthy had a little bit rough last
year with the cowboys i think it helps
having dan quinn to lean on all right
last one 2021 cowboys will win the nfc
east true or false
well i'm going to say true right now
because
as of today they have the best
quarterback in the div not realize he's
not signed i get that but
taking in everything into account that
prescott as their quarterback i think
they have the best quarterback in the
division we don't know what washington's
going to do with that position we don't
know ultimately what philadelphia will
end up but i'm saying right now today
they have the best quarterback we
haven't seen a team repeat in this
division i don't think since the
division came into play this four team
division that it is now the way it is
now a team has not repeated in this
division so that doesn't bode well for
washington i don't like philadelphia's
roster based on the salary cap that
their problems that they're gonna have
uh so i would say yes at this point mike
here's my problem the cowboys every year
fool me into thinking that because of
their talent they're going to be better
than they end up being i picked him to
be the number one seed in 2020. what the
hell was wrong with me so i'm gonna say
false i'm gonna say false just because i
think the giants are in a position to
make a jump
with the eagles who the hell knows
what's gonna happen but i like what
washington has going on even with a
quarterback change i like ron rivera i
like what he's done and i like what he
can do to get the most out of that team
all you got to have is the best record
of four teams that aren't that great and
i still think the cowboys are
away from being as great as jerry jones
needs them to be as he tries to get back
not just how about just get back to an
nfc championship game that hasn't
happened since 1995.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports